nfts absolutely exploding uh throughout
2021 for the record i told you back in
september of 2020 next big thing was
going to be nfts digital art et cetera
i'm not going to say it but i was right
so let's look at some charts first we
have the weekly nft buyers through the
end of june which shows both the primary
and the secondary market absolute
ridiculous growth from the first week of
uh january all the way through to the
end of june
and so that didn't stop there if you
actually buck it in q1 and q2 you can
see that literally it's almost off the
chart how much more nft activity was in
q1 and q2 you can see all the way back
in q1 of 2020 there was in u.s dollars
only 700 7.24
million dollars of quarterly sales
volume across various blockchains so
7.24 million dollars of quarterly sales
volume
that by q1 of 2021 was 1.23
billion dollars
insane growth in nfts q1 and q2 q2
higher highest quarter to date except
august happened and if we look at open
seas monthly volume from dune analytics
what we see is that in the month of
august
openc did over 3 billion dollars in
monthly sales volume
absolutely insane to see how much volume
they did
right now
at the end of august so over 3 billion
dollars now we've been spending a bunch
of time looking at nfts as much as i
joke around a lot uh i have been pretty
bullish on nfts for a while mainly
because it does two things one is it
takes intellectual property from the
analog world or from a digital world and
it introduces the ability to prove
scarcity so again that can be used for a
whole bunch of different reasons but the
idea that now in a digital world you can
prove scarcity don't trust verify you
can prove that scarcity is a really
really big deal but most people today
look at nfts and they kind of scratch
their head people are buying and selling
ether rocks for millions of dollars that
seems kind of ridiculous you just have a
picture of a fake rock they also looked
at things like nba topshop which was
real hot in q1 but is drastically drawn
down in terms of the volume nba top shot
obviously was uh the idea of taking
individual highlights from the nba and
auctioning them off to the free market
what the nba realized was that they were
drastically undervaluing their
intellectual property but who wants to
actually own a
random wednesday jump shot highlight
probably not that many people so what
you're starting to see is that it's not
just about owning something that looks
cool there's people who are spending
millions of dollars on apes or on crypto
punks or all kinds of different versions
of this but to me what's most
interesting is when you start to look
past this version of simply holding
something that looks cool so we've got
two examples uh one is this new release
of dak prescott who if you watched the
game last night what do we think johnny
looked pretty good killed it yeah i
thought i actually was playing pretty
well
dak prescott is the dallas cowboys
quarterback and so there's this new nft
that's being released it's a call it's
called a interactive nft what the hell
is an interactive nft well
what they're gonna do is when you buy
this and you hold it if dak prescott
does really well then you're going to
see that he's actually going to become
uh it's going to morph and it's going to
look differently so each week the nft
will change styles according to game
performance a standard performance of a
qbr rating of 60 to 75 sees dak in the
far right in that futuristic blue and
silver in throwing motion ready to lead
his team to victory a red hot
performance with a qbr rating of 75 or
more we'll see dak on the far left here
in fiery red being hoisted up by his
teammates okay and if he has a less than
a seller performance which happens
sometimes if his qbr rating is between
50 and 60 then he will simply be in a
storm with lightning striking looking
back but ready for the next play so when
you start to look at this it's the
equivalent as i wrote this morning of
your parents or your grandparents having
a signed baseball and all of a sudden
the baseball changes colors based on how
the team is doing or it would be like
the trophy on the mantle actually
morphing in physical form because that
player was doing better or worse
obviously in the physical world you
can't do this stuff but the idea of
interactivity is really interesting so
dak prescott there uh i think this one's
actually being auctioned right now i
don't think it's ended yet um but when
you look at this type of stuff to me
it's fascinating to say hey not only can
i bet on uh something or invest in
something as that thing becomes uh more
valuable because the player plays better
it'll actually change in form it'll
change colors it'll have motion it'll do
all these different things if the player
starts to suck and play badly it'll
change in reverse so pretty interesting
to see it the second example uh which we
don't have i i don't think it's going to
be easy to pull up so uh we'll just talk
about it is this whole idea of
an intelligent
avatar or an intelligent nft and so
there's this new company alfela who i've
actually talked to quite a bit in the
past and they've been iterating with
this technology they have trying to
figure out how can they actually
implement it but what you can do is you
can literally talk to the nft so you can
have an nft that you can say similar to
siri siri you know what's the weather
outside and it will respond to you and
it'll say the weather today is blah blah
whatever so it becomes much much more
interesting when you're talking about
these non-fungible assets
that have some sort of interactivity to
it or some sort of intelligence around
it that will allow you to actually use
the stuff it'll provide utility in some
form or fashion now everything is not
going to be valuable we still don't
understand how a lot of this stuff is
going to be used but similar to in the
1990s if somebody had said that was
working at a newspaper or at a media
company you know what we're gonna do the
internet sounds really cool we're gonna
take our newspaper we're gonna pdf it
and then we're going to simply upload it
to a static website
that would have gotten some level of
value from the internet but it would
have missed out on majority of the
functionality you wouldn't have the
ability to add multimedia you wouldn't
have the ability to collaborate to write
the article you wouldn't have real-time
editing you couldn't test headlines you
couldn't distribute via social media and
other types of things
and so instead what happened is the
media companies eventually realized the
full scale and value of the
functionality of the internet and they
said we're not just going to pdf our
newspapers and upload them instead we're
actually going to use this stuff to be
much much better over time i think
that's what we're watching happen in
real time here is the example of i built
10 000 apes sure it's cool people use it
from a status standpoint they're flexing
on other people on the internet but
ultimately where i think the world is
going is this whole idea of being able
to have interactivity and intelligence
in the nfts that provide more utility
and as these assets become the ability
to prove scarcity or originality in the
digital world i think we will see more
and more and more value now what i wrote
about this morning was last year in
september i wrote publicly i said look
there's about 10 million dollars so far
of market cap in the nft land the
traditional art market is estimated to
be 60 billion dollars so that would be a
6 000 x type upside well we've moved
really really fast and i probably was
underestimating how big that nft market
could get it's not just about digital
art it's going to seep into every single
industry it's going to seep into luxury
goods market it's going to seep into
collectibles it's going to seep into the
whole metaverse idea it's gonna seep
everywhere and the whole idea is because
now you can simply provide scarcity and
prove scarcity and originality in the
digital world
what do you think john
what do you think dak prescott's qbr and
what do you think that nft looks like
today fiery red ice
blue i think that he played very well
last night yeah so it's blue 74.3 oh
he's that right below
so he had to get the 75 and then it
would have been fiery red yep damn so
someone made a good point in this chat
and i'm curious what your thoughts are
around it is so when he stops playing
what happens to this nft does it become
more valuable does it become basically
worthless like what is the value of the
nft afterwards is it kind of like hey
don't get caught holding the bag at the
end which i think a lot of people are
nervous about in this space look i i
don't know the answer is kind of the
crazy part right and i think that that's
part of what needs to be figured out
here is um look at think of signatures
for example right uh there's a world
where people sign
nearly nothing right darren rovell came
on he was talking about all these
signatures that he had all these
autographs on on physical items and the
more that somebody has signed things the
less valuable the autograph is right so
there's a built-in scarcity you can't
prove what the scarcity is but just
people know hey not that many people
have martin luther king's signature on
some item right
now
if you flood the market with autographs
the value goes down but then if you die
maybe the value of the autographs go
back up so it's not just uh oh
everything's gonna go up or everything's
gonna go down when someone gets done
playing it's also very um uh reliant on
other things that happen as well and so
in a world where dak prescott plays
really well he goes and he wins the
super bowl you're probably way more
valuable than it is today if he goes in
he wins the super bowl the value goes up
and then all of a sudden he absolutely
sucks for three years and then the value
goes back down right like it's not a
kind of static state i think it's
actually evolving over time so you're
saying that in the future this will be
used as kind of like a modern day like i
have an autograph but i can prove how
scarce it is like is that are people
going to be showing off their nfts when
you go to their home
i think that there's a couple of
different versions of this right so
there's uh digital art that will be
displayed inside a home right so like
what my original thesis was real simple
so something like this um if i hang up
art in my house that art is static
there's no sound there's no motion and
if i want to change the art i got to
take it off the wall and put something
else yeah right and then on top of that
it's really hard to prove that it's uh
authentic that it's real that it's not a
fake and also that i own it right so
there's a whole bunch of things that go
in there if now i just hang up a screen
on the wall and i can put a digital item
it can look exactly the same just a
static image it can be motion it can be
sound i can change it i have it changed
by the hour by the season by who's in
the house uh by nighttime to daytime odd
stuff now how many people want to do
that i don't know but but it's possible
to do it when you then look and say but
is it just about hanging it on your wall
or is it actually about well what
happens when we go and we hang out in
these virtual worlds and then you can't
bring the physical art so i don't care
so much about how do we take the
existing world and just replicate it in
the new world what i look for is this
new technology what does it now empower
that previously wasn't available
go ahead yeah so my former employer
fortune magazine recently sold 256
limited edition nfts of its latest cover
the magazine cover they sold 256 of them
for 1.3 million dollars in total is this
smart for media companies to be doing
this i know time magazine has also done
it but
wha who okay if i buy that what am i
doing with this cover
well so they're collectible i mean
people just collect the regular uh cover
anyways right like how many people have
like collections of uh time magazine or
for i mean you literally have them right
so now you just have it in a digital
format so there's like that element of
it but ultimately like a lot of value
in the world
is derived from narratives and i think
part of what's so weird about this is if
you went back and you said to yourself
hey uh people are going to consume
majority of their information on the
internet rather than from a physical
newspaper there was a time in the world
where that was impossible to see the
future i mean people like that's crazy
why would i ever go and spend 50 000
on this big computer thing and then go
just to read the news i can just pick up
the newspaper on the street corner
now
how many people read the newspaper right
like the actual physical newspaper so
little it almost seems our cake or like
dinosaur land to do that and so i think
the same thing happens here which is uh
when new technology is created it
empowers new things and those new things
allow entrepreneurs and creators or like
creative people to do stuff we haven't
imagined yet so a great example is uber
uber was not possible
until we got the iphone the iphone was
the first time that we had a super
computer-like capability with gps in it
and when you get the gps in a physical
device now you can have the driver and
the rider both be able to find each
other in a very simple way so literally
the smartphone with gps unlocked the
ability to get an uber like product but
before the iphone you couldn't do that
and so i think that ends up being what
what's really important is understanding
that this technology unlocks new things
i if i knew the answers i'd go build it
i i don't know so i'm waiting for other
people to figure out all the ways to use
this come to if you're building
something here come tell us and then
we'll look we'll look at it maybe invest
is this going to be a combination uh
going forward like vr and nfts similar
to i mean you did the experience where
we actually went in vr and we could tour
a building
in vr and the whole idea is that you can
tour from many different places you can
all do at the same time like is this
what it's going to like being an
architect in the virtual reality world
is going to be just as valuable as being
architect in
real life
yeah i mean absolutely right if you
start to think about uh and it's why i
tweeted the other day we already live in
virtual reality right when i go into the
portal on my phone right i go into this
portal and i'm hanging out in a digital
square and i'm communicating with other
people in that digital or virtual
environment right twitter that's what we
do every day we all show up to this
virtual world we all communicate with
each other and it's like walking around
the virtual square and being like oh
what's john talking about now i don't
care what's plain to talk about i don't
care oh what's up oh i like what joe's
talking about today let me jump into the
conversation and i can reply to them i
can do all that but it's fast they're
easier
now it doesn't when you hear virtual
reality you think like you put on the
headset you go we can see each other
like it seems weird right but we're
already doing some version of this to me
it is we went from none of it to like a
watered-down version of it eventually
we'll get an even bigger version of it
etc but i think that people have to
understand like in that virtual world in
order for that to become reality then
you have to have the technology that you
build assets scarcity originality uh all
that type of stuff and so there's gonna
be a day where somebody wakes up and
literally their job is not to be an
architect in the real world it's gonna
be an architect in the virtual world and
to some degree what do we do today most
architects don't draw by hand they
create it in a virtual world and then
they basically take the model and they
say okay let's build this in the
physical world but at some point they're
just going to draw it in the physics in
the virtual world they're going to say
okay here it is here's this cool thing
that i built i like uh ethernet the the
example you showed of dak prescott i
like what they're doing uh within sports
i think sports is unique because there's
clearly demand for it from a a trading
card and a collection and memorabilia
perspective like that's already an
existing market uh sorry for the dog
barking someone knocked on the door uh
but
yeah so i think uh authority is an
interesting company lamellar ball did
very something very similar to what
they're doing with that dak prescott
which was
he uh he releases nfts it's based on
supply and demand so there's a capped or
constrained supply and then he updates
it based on achievements right so you
bought it during his rookie year if he
wins uh mvp eventually if he wins the
title whatever these awards get added to
his nft potentially increasing the value
theoretically right so i think things
like that are unique but for entities in
general um
i i think it's less about like the
conversation that you guys were having
earlier about like displaying in your
house it's more about uh the combination
of things
in the in the digital world right which
is social value for decades and hundreds
of years people have depended on things
for social value whether it's a nice car
a nice house a bag whatever it is right
so nfts display that knowing that if you
own a crypto punk and you paid a million
dollars for whatever is that gives some
value or status to you so i think that's
important uh the community is obviously
important all these people have discord
channels and stuff where you can
interact with people in the communities
are very strong
same thing as whether you're uh you know
a fan of bitcoin uh you ride a peloton
whatever it is right the community
aspect is important and then i think
utility is like the uh the last factor
that adds all the value right which is
giving someone the ability to uh have
some utility off of these nfts whether
it's hey i sell five nfts joe nfts you
get to come to dinner with me once a
year or i send you something or whatever
it is right there's there's different
things you can do uh that add utility to
it for the uh for the holder and i think
it's gonna play out just like everything
else which is based on supply and demand
right if the mark gets oversaturated the
prices will continue to cut will come
down uh but at the end of the day people
want digital collectibles it's clearly
something that's going to be here for
the long term uh it's just depending on
kind of like figuring out
how to value these things correctly the
ip on them
and different athletes working with
different companies to build out their
portfolios joe what is the most
interesting thing that you've seen
because i guess the other one is like
lamelo ball had one where like as he
wins awards and stuff it acquires uh
like virtual trophies or something
yeah yeah so like uh that's obviously an
interesting one i think there's like two
categories right and there's there's
certainly people that have done uh
really good ones and some that i would
claim are not as good and the two
categories would be people that are just
releasing the nft right and what they're
doing is they're uh basically they're
commissioning an artist or whoever it is
and they're building the nft and they're
releasing it and uh maybe they do one
drop or two drops or whatever but
there's no kind of add-on value after
that they collect a percentage fee two
and a half five percent whatever it ends
up being uh on secondary transactions
and that's kind of their drop and they
they let it go maybe there's a community
aspect to it but typically not really so
a bunch of professional athletes have
done that uh
from 12 months ago six months ago even
currently people are still doing that
the people that i think have done them
really well the mellow ball is one
example uh he's added value to it and he
he owns uh some entities himself so he's
obviously very active in the community
the pll we talked about on the show a
while ago did a really cool one which
was uh you got access to a bunch of
things right there the pll is the
premier lacrosse league for people who
don't know about it
and they uh they released an nft for
each team there's 12 teams in league
there was 12 nfts and each one
essentially made you a team owner so you
got access uh you had a call with a
commissioner you had a call with the
head coach every week uh you got to go
to the awards ceremony the end of the
year and you had this nft that you could
trade on the secondary market so i think
that the people that are doing it really
well uh i think we're going to see a
bunch of professional athletes release
more interactive ones so we had a
conversation with a professional athlete
a few weeks ago and his whole idea was
pitched around he's a an nba all-star
and his idea was essentially to release
an nft uh he's got a signature shoe
coming out and say hey look you'll get
the first drop of the signature shoes
i'll take you out to a game you'll get
quartzite seats one time right and if
you do it based on a limited supply so
there's only five there's only six
available you can quickly see how the
super fans for these players uh bid
these up really quickly they change
hands a couple times and they get these
awesome rewards so i think the people
that have done them really well on an
individual level are the ones that are
thinking about in that capacity the
companies uh i think authority is a
really good example because they've done
these with a bunch of different athletes
and the thing that they've done really
well is they've gone out and got in
premium exclusive ip right so they have
uh leo messi they have dak prescott and
they have a bunch of other athletes and
what they're saying is hey look we're
going to be your nft provider and we're
going to do these drops we're going to
update them we're going to do cool and
interactive things like the dak press
got the hot the cold the medium whatever
it ends up being but i think uh from a
company's standpoint they've done a
really good job in exploring the space
and doing some really cool things yeah
but joe is that value being created from
the interactive aspect of going to the
game going to dinner right so we had
ricky williams on the show you missed it
yesterday but we had ricky williams
talking about he did something similar
with the university of texas right so
you could buy the nft but it also gave
you access to have dinner and all these
other aspects to it like can you does it
still retain the same value if you use
those perks and then have the nft
afterwards
yeah well i think it's all that's part
of the value right and that's part of
the uh the holistic approach to buying
these things and i think that's why some
people have a difficult time grasping
why a rock is worth so much right
because you don't get anything from it
it's all based on scarcity you're saying
hey look i only i know that there's only
x number of these this one's super
valuable because people are willing to
buy it at this price right and that's
really what it comes down to is just the
supply and demand but when you're able
to put tangible things of utility on the
nft also and you say hey look i know if
i buy this for ten thousand dollars i'm
gonna get to go to a game and say
courtside i know i'm gonna get to go to
dinner with this athlete i know i'm
gonna get access to this whatever it
might be you can start to put more
tangible values on the nft and actually
grade it appropriately and i think those
are the nfts that will become more
mainstream because people can grasp them
right it doesn't take a mass
understanding of the digital world to
understand why those have value because
you're getting something in return right
so the rocks are difficult and crypto
punks are difficult because it's all
just based off of supply and demand
people understand that are naturally
involved in the space but when you're
actually getting something tangible or
physical in return it makes it much
easier to understand the value so those
gifts and those things have to be
updated on on an annual basis right if
you tell me hey i'm going to release an
nft
it's only going to come out uh and
you're going to get these rewards for
the first year the nft loses a drastic
amount of value in year two if those
rewards don't keep uh kind of uh
replacing themselves to some degree so i
think the athlete has to be mindful that
this is a continuous thing and maybe
it's not in-person things maybe it's
easier things like hey you get access to
my merchandise you get this or that or
you get to join a group or whatever it
is things that don't take as much leg
work but i think the tricky part is uh
finding things that will have continuous
value that people want and are
interested in and then i think it's it's
figuring out how to uh do the supply and
demand of like how much cap how much
upside do you cap what do you bake into
the uh the transaction fee that you get
yourself how do you think about it from
a uh kind of like a mass approach or a
limited approach so i think we're gonna
see people continue to do a bunch of
different drops athlete-wise we'll see
some succeed we'll see others fail but i
think uh what we'll see is people will
adapt more to the things where they get
physical uh physical items in return or
or uh experiences per se more so than
just things that are kept on supply and
demand
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofi
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]